the danger theory is the theory of why
the immune system reacts to damage and
this little demonstration is designed to
show why now as computer scientists
we're not usually known for our physical
demonstrations as our physics and
chemistry counterparts if this goes
horrific ly wrong
so yeah right so we'll go here i've got
a balloon with some bits in it and this
represents a cell that has obviously
some internal constituents so in the
cell you've got things like the nucleus
which contains the rough and the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum and also things
little organelles called mitochondria so
cells are filled with quite a lot of
stuff and all of this stuff is kept
behind a cell membrane and that keeps
the cell intact and there are two
different ways in which a cell can die
the cells can die in a planned way
called apoptosis or can die in an
unplanned way called necrosis now the
immune system is clever enough to detect
whether it's tissue cells are dying from
necrosis or apoptosis and in apoptosis
what we have is we have a cell and it
receives something called a death signal
so this happens when cells just die
because of the cell turnover or during
or during development for example we in
the womb have webbing between our
fingers and apoptosis gets rid of those
excess cells so that's the process of
in a controlled manner so what happens
is it's a very energy energetically
consumptive process so it consumes a lot
of energy to do this and what happens is
is a molecule will will bind to the cell
and will tell the seller it's time to
die and what happens is the cell
degrades in a very slow very controlled
process as demonstrated by me simply
letting the air as to this balloon like
so and what's important about this
process is that everything that is
contained within the cell membrane it's
still contained within the cell membrane
so when the cell dies it dies off
eventually
it shrinks and become so small that a
t-cell from the immune system or a
phagocyte can come along and will just
simply eat it up right so the important
thing about that process is the cells
now died and everything that was with
within the cell membrane is still within
that cell membrane now it's being
digested conversely in necrosis necrosis
is where you get an injury to the cell
and there are several different
mechanisms which can cause cell injury
one of those is bacteria one of those is
viruses heat excessive cold UV radiation
free radicals lots of different ways a
cell can die but generally it's what you
want the immune system to detect this so
how it does it is this again we have our
cell with all the all its little bits
inside it but how apoptosis
is a very controlled and very graceful
process the process of necrosis is a
little bit different it's quite
unplanned and what happens is exactly
that just as the balloon exploded the
cell explodes and as you can see my
office is now covered in these small
silver stars everything that was inside
the cell is now outside of the cell the
immune system can detect these little
molecules which is a rapid response to
the oxidation of the molecules of the
the bits that were inside the cell and
that's how the immune system uses the
danger theory and tells the difference
between apoptosis and necrosis